California State Democratic convention
is underway in San Francisco this
weekend more than a dozen of the 23
presidential hopefuls are expected to
make speeches at the event or make
campaign stops in California this
weekend as ed O'Keefe reports for the
first time in a long time
the Golden State is offering up an early
political treasure to the candidates I
don't want to get my opponents nervous
we're going to win here in California
the Democratic presidential race heads
through California this weekend not a
usual stop this early in a campaign so
I'm here because I believe that in this
country everybody counts then we need a
president that believes that everybody
counts the Golden State usually serves
as more of an ATM for presidential
candidates raising campaign cash but
it's earning far more attention from
contenders this time meaning the state's
more liberal voters will have a bigger
say in the contest we're here to listen
to them but we also need to have them
listen to us we're not just a piggy bank
candidates are spending more time in
California because unlike past elections
the state will hold its primary next
year on Super Tuesday the nation's
biggest state will award the biggest
prize four hundred ninety five delegates
and because most delegates will be
awarded proportionally several
candidates could walk away with wins
making the Golden State a critical stop
the party's frontrunner former Vice
President Joe Biden is campaigning this
weekend in Ohio but more than a dozen
other contenders are in San Francisco to
speak at the state Democratic convention
delegates say they're eager for the
attention usually given to places like
Iowa and New Hampshire
elections we get kind of neglected as oh
that blue state or the big save and it's
nice knowing that they actually seem to
care about us right now what's the one
issue out here they're going to have to
really talk about in order to get
people's attention well there's more
than one so taxes climb
education one other big factor here in
California
early voting ballots will be mailed to
voters across the state next year on the
same day as the caucuses in Iowa all the
more reason for presidential candidates
like Elizabeth Warren to show up here
early and often for CBS this morning
Saturday ed O'Keefe Oakland California